إذا حاولت أن أتخيل كيف سيبدو مطبخك
في غضون 10 سنوات ، فقد
يكون لديك جهاز إضافي لا
يتوفر به اليوم وستكون هناك طابعة طعام
أو ربما سيكون اسمًا أكثر جنسية
له ولكنه يتيح لك ذلك  القيام بأشياء
لا يمكنك القيام بها اليوم ، من السهل رفض
الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد للطعام باعتباره حداثة ولكن في
مختبر الآلات الإبداعية في كولومبيا ،
يتوقعون أن مطبخك المستقبلي قد
يحتوي على طابعة ثلاثية الأبعاد في الوقت الحالي ، ما
يخرج من الآلات لم يتم طهيه على هذا النحو
يحاول الفريق اكتشاف أفضل طريقة
لطهي الطعام أثناء طباعته ، فلماذا
تحتاج إلى دمج الليزر في الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
حتى تقدم لك الليزر دقة أعلى بكثير
مع الطهي بدلاً من
طرق الطهي التقليدية مثل
استخدام الفرن ولكن الليزر يمنحك  هذه
الدقة والدقة هي الدقة
التي تحتاجها لأنه الآن نقطة
طاقة يمكنك التحكم فيها حيث
يذهب هذا الرجل يقوم فقط بتحمير الجزء العلوي
ويتم طهيه فقط أقل بقليل
من ملليمتر من العجين في الجزء العلوي الذي
لا يتحول إلى اللون البني.  يبدو الأمر كثيرًا ولكن مرة أخرى إذا
كنت تفكر في كيفية
استخدام هذه الأشياء على طابعة طعام ثلاثية الأبعاد ، فأنت
تضعها على حوالي ملليمتر واحد
فقط للطعام ، لذا فأنت تحتاج حقًا إلى طهي واحد
إلى مليمترين فقط
ما هو الجدول الزمني  التحدث هنا
عندما تعتقد أن هذا سيكون
أمرًا شائعًا في مطابخ الناس ،
فهذه الطابعات بالليزر من
الصعب التنبؤ بها لأنها
مسألة تجارية أكثر من غيرها من
التقنيات التكنولوجية هنا إذا
أرادت شركة أن تأخذ هذا وتشغيله.
في عام
وأنت
[موسيقى]